hello everybody
hope everybody is doing well today
give me a few seconds because
i accidentally
accidentally closed the file that had
all the questions in it here we go
all right
all right so we should be good
all right hope everybody's well i um
this last month has been completely mad
for those who have been following me
um
there's been a lot of stuff going on
that's why i've actually made uh i think
i made like one less video this month
just because
um jordan peterson asked me to come up
to toronto i spent several days there
with his um with his family i hadn't
seen him since 2018 which was which was
crazy and so we filmed some stuff at his
house and with john verveigh and then
when i came back he asked me to come
also to montreal i was doing an event
with him in montreal
which i turned out turned out i was on
the stage with him the whole time asking
questions and stuff so it was pretty
wild i'd never talked to so many people
it's like like 1700 people
and so that and everything that kind of
came around that
more kind of interviews and people uh
wanting to talk to me has made the last
month quite uh quite crazy
and so uh but you know everything is is
all good
i hope everybody's well all right so
let's start and see if we've got some
interesting questions in the chat let's
see do i have some announcements to make
um
probably not for those who are still
waiting for god's dog it is on the boat
it's all i can say it's coming to the
warehouse everything is set up we're
just waiting for the books to arrive and
then we will we will ship them it's
still going to take a little while i
guess everything just takes so much
longer than what i'd hoped for and so i
apologize for people who are waiting for
the book
it's coming we definitely will not make
the same mistake for book two we will
make sure that everything is kind of set
up and everything is ready before we
move ahead and tell people
uh either we're gonna do another
crowdfunding or however we're gonna do
it we're gonna make sure that we don't
have people waiting for like eight
months before they get the book
so that's uh that's important um
what else is there and so all right
let's go so let's see
simeon andreas asked what is the
relationship between emergence and god's
continual creation
and so
i mean that's a good way to kind of
understand it actually is that the
notion that god is kind of holding
reality together has to do with this
continued manifestation of of the logos
of identity and of let's say things
binding together towards their purposes
and so that is the way in which
we could say that god sustains creation
is through that very pattern
and and so i think that that's the best
way to understand it
um
so undying nephilim
nice name
here's a question is there any positive
use for ai or is it doomed to become
some kind of modern idol
and so i think just like anything
there's positive uses for anything the
problem is always hierarchy the problem
is always
you know the difficulty with something
like ai is that the amount of energy
and effort it takes to bring it about
makes it difficult for it not to kind of
become a primary
place for attention and doesn't kind of
take up this this central space and so
that's what makes it difficult to think
that it won't end up becoming something
like a
something like an idol you know i think
so it's hard to know and it's also
there's obviously there are many ais
that are
secondary um and that are used for all
kinds of reasons which is totally fine
if they're used as tools it's mostly the
the very idea that ai is going to kind
of solve our problems it's going to
solve our problems of of of meaning
and a purpose
and of course the craziest idea is in
the transhumanist idea that the ai is
going to kind of transcend us and it's
going to replace us in a certain manner
the fact that humans are even willing to
go there and to posit such theories
is uh
is pretty frightening
so frederick gopher schmidt says why
does jesus hold the sword in his left
hand so he's less likely to use it
that's funny uh i mean i mean it depends
usually we rarely show christ holding a
sword by the way sometimes you'll see in
images of revelation sometimes you'll
see like a sword coming out of his mouth
and usually it is on the left side and
so if you have seen images of christ
holding a sword with his left hand it
has to do with the fact that
the left hand in
when christ talks to the goat and the
sheep he says to the
to the to the sheep come closer and to
the goats you know move away and so the
sword is the one that separates it so
you can understand the left hand as
being that which separates and then the
right hand is that which unifies it kind
of has this kind of you know this idea
of coagulation and and the dissolution
um
i did it the opposite though dissolution
on the left hand and coagulation on the
right hand so um yeah exactly so undying
nephilim says i've regretted my name
choice for almost a decade
that's hilarious man
you know you are allowed to change your
name online that is something that could
happen but i get it all right so let's
go into the uh i'm gonna go into the
questions now so as people know uh
people who um
who support me on patreon for ten
dollars or more get to ask questions in
advance
and then people that in general on
patreon or on facebook and the facebook
group can uh they can follow this live
and then this will be posted later so
those that come in live they can ask
questions in the chat as well so that's
a way for me to try to give as many
possibilities to participate without the
kind of craziness of being completely
live which
is difficult to manage with all the
people spamming and stuff
all right so we'll start with questions
that come from the
website
so a riddle asks at one of the small
group meetings we talked about secrets
and hiddenness versus disclosure he
reminded me of how people will cross
their fingers behind their back when
lying or make an oath they don't plan to
keep
how should we think about the symbolic
meaning of this actions would it be
right to understand it
simply as an inversion of the sign of
the cross
no i don't know if you could see it as
the sign of the cross i think that
there's a few things going on with that
sign it's pretty primordial if you think
about it and so there are two things
going on one has to do with the
the fact that when you cross your
fingers you're not you're not straight
it's you're crooked your fingers are
crooked and so you're hiding the fact
that you're
that you're crooked uh that is what's
going on there but then the other one i
think it also has to do with the x the
idea of crossing something out in order
to remove it you know if you have
if you have something you don't want you
cross it out like a name or something
like that if you put a cross on top of a
name especially if that's a pretty uh i
mean at least in the west a pretty
universal sign that it's you that you
are that you're eliminating it as a
meaning-making thing so i think that
that's probably what's going on there if
you know it's uh it's definitely a very
primordial gesture
so uh mark
asked a greeting from tbilisi
he says if you agree that theosis is the
ultimate guiding star does a theoretical
understanding of symbology have any
utility
and so i mean i think so i think that
just like anything i mean you could ask
that question about a theoretical
knowledge of
of anything right you could say
you could say something like since the
purpose of cooking is to eat good food
is a theoretical knowledge of recipes uh
useful and the answer is yes of course
it's not the purpose it's not the goal
but it's something that can kind of help
you along your way and kind of see
things in the proper frame so i think
it's the same for studying theology in
general it's the same for reading the
bible it's the same for having any
theoretical knowledge that is related to
the spiritual life i think that for sure
symbolic understanding or at least
symbolic perception can help you see the
analogies and kind of give you that
sense of wonder that can motivate you as
well to uh
to take your spiritual life seriously
all right and so
so
undying nephilim that wants to change
his name to maybe repentant nephilim
that's awesome you should do that
all right so jay grubb says uh
could you comment on the symbolism of
the compass point and how their
associations flip between the northern
and southern hemispheres as do seasons
for instance the north is associated
with with cold often with masculine etc
in the northern hemisphere but in the
southern
southern the association would seem to
be the opposite and so
yeah i mean i think that this is
something now the thing you need to
understand is that in the ancient world
the southern hemisphere was just not
available it would just was not
accessible
you have to understand that for example
in in or if it was it was very little
was known about it you know it was very
mysterious because in africa you would
first of all you had the sahara desert
which separated africa into two really
spaces like two massive spaces and so of
course there was some people there
probably were some people going down the
coast of africa to get uh different
materials and slaves but it was probably
quite rarely and then the news of that
would make it back to
to the levante to you know to europe or
to to
other places very diff very with great
difficulty and would come back and
twisted with all these kind of legendary
images you know of elephants and all
these wild animals that they would see
there um but i think that this image was
actually captured mythologically in the
idea that
that in the southern hemisphere it's
it's the antipodes
and that people are upside down and so
of course
we can understand that we find it funny
now to think that people are upside down
but there there really is a flip that
happens like you said which is that when
you cross the when you cross the equator
the world flips upside down and all of a
sudden the the the uh
the um
the seasons flip you know the uh the
orientation flips and so i think that
that's
probably a kind of mythological
capturing of
of some knowledge of how it worked when
you would go down to the southern
hemisphere you know um you know and
right becomes left like we knew seen the
coriolis effect like it flips to the
other side so um you know
i think that that's definitely something
that that is going on
all right so c streets will asks
if those who live by the sword are to
die by the sword can christians serve in
the military and law enforcement while
strictly adhering to the teachings of
christ particularly if the state or
political body has values at odds with
the christian values but if the country
fights a war of aggression or institutes
a law that it enforced would violate
christian ethics the christians in or
considering these roles need to choose
professions that are not as morally
fraught rules that do not require
violence to enforce the will of the
state
how do we support the rule of law
without being corrupt by the evils of
our nations and so of course this is a
very difficult question
i think for sure christians can serve in
the military
but i think that in doing so
they obviously opened themselves to
certain dangers i mean everybody has
certain dangers but people who were in
the military will open themselves to
particular dangers of course the idea of
being in a position of expressing power
whether it's a police whether it's you
know someone who has a weapon and can
can apply their power on others then
these are the kinds of temptations that
you will have and so you have to be very
careful
to
yeah you have to be careful and so
when it comes to actually fighting in
wars
at least in the byzantine emperor at
least in the orthodox tradition there's
a sense in which
we understand that war is kind of an
inevitable part of this world and it is
kind of a dark part of this world
and uh
and so this is usually represented by
the fact that people who go to war have
to uh go through some kind of
purification when they when they
come back and want to commune they have
to confess and they're i don't know
exactly what it is but they they don't
they can't just go into church and and
take communion they have to kind of go
through a process of progression and um
so i think that that's an image of it's
an image of that but for sure
i would say that on the positive side
there's an aspect of the military and
the police which can manifest christian
virtues in terms of helping the weak in
terms of defending those that can't
defend themselves um you know in terms
of serving understanding what it means
to serve in a hierarchy you see that you
know christ
talks about that when he talks to the
roman centurion
and you know he actually
he actually says that the roman
centurion because the roman centurion
understands christ because he can see
that he's in the in a chain of command
and that he can understand the way in
which christ can act in the world
uh because he's in this chain of command
and he can kind of see it as analogous
to the man in which christ can command
the angels you could say in order to act
and so i think that that that is also
something which is probably um
useful
um
so but you you're right and so as if i
think that christians are responsible
you know in terms of unjust killing
they have a special responsibility to be
careful of that
and you can see it in the story of the
martyrs where for example you would have
roman soldiers that are persecuting
christians and would kill christians
then suddenly one of the soldiers would
see that this is unjust
and would actually join the people
getting killed and have this conversion
uh and be killed with the martyrs you
know and they they would say that they
were baptized in blood at that point and
so i think that there's also a call to
be attentive to that and if
and if your your country is doing things
that are completely
that are completely wrong
then
yeah you know but i would hate to be in
that situation because it's very
difficult
yep
all right so in the chat frederick
gopher schmidt asks
if you you once said that possibly
luther should have become a martyr for
the catholic church are you saying it's
wrong to leave your church if you
believe they have lost their way
and so
i think that
i think there's a difference for example
between leaving a parish like leaving a
specific church where there's some kind
of
breakdown where there's you know a
evil pastor or priest or there's you
know these things happen you know they
can definitely happen you have abusive
uh priests or you have uh dishonest
corrupt people in the hierarchy and so i
think there's a difference between that
and let's say leaving the church all
together and i think that that's the
problem that happened with martin luther
is that he
not only that he left his church not
only that he left the catholic church
but that he in a way started his own
church
and took upon himself the power to name
priests and to kind of recreate a church
on the side and so i think that in doing
so
he basically inaugurated the the ma one
the fragmentation of the of the west
and
so that's what i think um but i do think
that if you're in a church that is
completely off the rails and that is
wrong or that is is bad i think you
should leave it
um definitely so
don't charge your don't start your own
church though
just don't do that
um
and it's messy here now it's messier now
because at the time of luther there was
just one option it was like
there was just one church and there
there were a few little heretical sects
that would appear here and there but now
it's messier because there's like you
know there's a million churches with a
million denominations which is an image
of the problem itself and a breakdown so
yeah
all right and so logos 85 back to the
website what is the symbolic
significance of the ancient feminine
goddess statue
such as the the venus of willendorf and
the sheila in a gig how do you respond
to those who view the prime world of
religion as primarily feminine based on
artifacts such as these and how does the
theodogus fit into this tradition
all right let me say this
no one knows what those statuettes are
no one knows what they're about
they are an image of a lost memory they
are an image of a of something which is
so completely cut off from us that it
manifests itself as a total alien and
becomes the space of every projection
that you can imagine that's the problem
of losing memory it's a problem of
of
of cutting the line cutting the line of
memory of tradition that binds you to
the past so the people go and dig into
the ground and find these dead bodies
like these are dead things and then they
raise them up it's a form of necromancy
and then they try to blow spirit back
into that and what they and what they
end up doing it's always super
subversive it's always like exactly what
you said it's like
oh here's the primordial religion it's
what i want it to be it's these feminine
goddesses you know it's like okay dude
you have no idea what those statuettes
are for let let's let's let's speculate
just for fun you know it's like why do
you think that those statuettes were
were goddesses why don't you think that
those statuettes were apotropaic
that is maybe they were maybe they were
gargoyles maybe they were magic monsters
and that's why they're so huge and fat
and weird and they were just these like
these monsters that people use to
protect themselves from demons and we're
not saying that's what it is i'm saying
there's no more reason to think that
these were apotropaic than to think that
they were goddesses that people
worshipped or to think that they were
dolls that kids played with or to think
anything like who knows like they have
no idea they find these dead things and
so apply this now to
all the things people are always saying
you see the same like people finding
things on minos you know they found
these like snake goddesses they they
don't know what they are they find these
women holding snakes all right okay
you have no idea there's no tradition
there's no link
and so and so
you'll see it like archaeologists are
necromancers like constantly and and and
what happens with the necromancy is that
they pre they just project their
fantasies and so these types of statues
have been used to kind of undermine
christianity and oh take a question of
what really was the primordial religion
maybe it was this this feminine goddess
you know it's like man
it's all
you have to see that it's all narrative
twist and it's all this it's all it
really is a kind of magic trick that
that the necromancer is playing on you
it's like reviving these dead bodies
with his own spirit and making it speak
like a like a marionette you know to
speak their own philosophy and their own
ideas
so yeah don't get swayed by these
archaeologists they have no idea what
they're talking about like especially
i'm not saying if you find something
that's related to to a
civilization that we have connection
with that there's a tradition that
there's a line that we have some memory
of but when you find something that's 30
000 years old in the ground
yeah might as well be looking at aliens
like you might as well be looking at any
you don't know what it is
all right sorry
i have no i'm just not impressed by
these things
all right so cormac jones says in the
life of saint martins of tours saint
martin of tours there's a story about a
holy place where people gather to
worship that same mind feels unsure
about due to the vagueness of its
history abstains from worshiping there
but doesn't forbid others too until that
is one day he goes there and has a
vision that the martyrs relics upon
which it's built are actually those of a
wretched thief and the whole spiritual
foundation of place is a delusion and a
lie my question is how likely do you
think it is for false symbolic
hierarchies to survive in practice
when there isn't a saint martin around
to expose them
what is their value to the people who
participate in them
said differently how faulty can the test
of time be and how much should we worry
about it so i think you shouldn't worry
about it but i think what it does this
story is particularly important is it
shows you the difference between between
something like
uh organizational hierarchy which is
important let's say like the way in
which the tradition kind of sets itself
up with priests and bishops and
buildings and you know and
fittings and all this kind of stuff that
manifests the exterior aspect of of the
hierarchy but then the true hierarchy is
the spiritual hierarchy the true
hierarchy is a hierarchy of saint and
this this story shows us that
that it is ultimately the saint which is
the root of
the christian tradition
and that
the the saint if he shows himself to be
a saint and he's recognized as having
spiritual authority
yeah can do things like that can let's
say see under the appearances and find
the the like the corrupt worms and kind
of pull them out and so
i think that that's what that that story
is about there there are other types of
other versions of this type of story
where saints are able to expose the
hypocrisy and the lies that are in the
external hierarchy you see it in the
story of christ himself now of course we
need we can't go too far and decide that
because of that the exterior kind of
hierarchy of the church and
it's it's it's outer structures that
they're useless that they're that we
should get rid of them and everything um
yeah
so
all right so joel
g caesar says do you have any thoughts
in the conversation between brett
weinstein and bishop
baron
uh and so you're lucky that i listened
to that i was into that yesterday by the
way i'm supposed to talk to brett
weinstein tomorrow and so i really
tomorrow morning i have to get up early
and listen to our to our podcast again
so i can kind of go over to what we
talked about um
i thought it was interesting i thought
that it had similar issues that i felt i
had with brett as well which is always
the problem
of postulating a moral order and not
being able
to know
where it comes from uh and so but one
thing that happened in the discussion
with bishop baron is i think that to a
certain extent stand heather and him
uh
is that her name i think so
sorry if that's not her name um
that she that they that they acknowledge
that science doesn't have that answer
that basically it has to come from
somewhere else
and uh and that as scientists they're
maybe not the ones to be able to say
where that comes from and so i kind of
got a little bit of that so that's
interesting it's interesting but he's
also kind of saying then i can't really
think about this stuff like i don't it's
not part of my
part my worldview but at the same time
he's he's gesturing to it so
that's a little bit of an issue i think
um
so i'm let's see let's see how it goes
tomorrow i'm a little worried because i
felt like our last conversation lasted
three hours and
i didn't feel like we we got very far
but let's see we'll see
um
all right so wedge young man asked in a
recent discussion between dreampiece and
roger penrose
the possibility of a cyclical universe
was suggested
do you think this theory is compatible
with christianity
a universe with no beginning or end
oh my goodness
all right sorry sorry that i'm doing
that
so
it's very simple guys the beginning is
not in the universe the end is not in
the universe
it's as simple as that
and so you will never find the beginning
of the universe in the universe and
you'll never find the end of the
universe in the universe
just like you won't find the beginning
of a
of anything in the thing itself
right the the origin of something is not
in the thing
i don't know what to say and so it's
like that's why they'll never get to the
big bang or whatever that's why they'll
never be able that's why they'll come up
with theories like this that's why
they'll have some asymptotic you know uh
definitions of time where where time you
know slows or
time kind of moves and then doesn't
reach the beginning and becomes like
this asymptotal uh formula where it
never reaches the beginning so because
you can't
you can't have the the reason and the
origin of the system inside the system
it's like that for everything it sounds
like that every level of reality and
it's ultimately like that for the the
whole the whole thing so
so yeah whatever that's fine like if you
want to posit that that's fine but it
doesn't mean that there's no beginning
there's no end just mean that it's not
inside it's not in it's a it's you could
say it's something like an infinite
beginning and an infinite end you know
if you want to if you want to to say it
that way uh so
so yeah so i'm not impressed by these
kinds of these kinds of uh these kinds
of arguments especially i'm not
impressed by them if people think that
by making these arguments
that they are somehow
disproving you know the idea that the
the the
universe has an origin it's like
no you're not disproving anything
that's what an origin is
you know
sorry i'm a little i mean i need to calm
down
all right so bluemix asked the statue of
nebuchadnezzar's dream starts with the
most precious metal
at the top and goes down to lester
medals why is babylon represented with
the most precious metal
the other empires with the lesser
especially since babylonian civilization
has ceased to exist whereas persian in
greek and arguably rome cultures still
exist not though not as they used to
and so
the the important part of that
has to do so the idea of lesser metals
is you have to be careful that it's not
just about lesser
it is also about there's a relationship
of
of precious
let's say and uh
malleable
and then there's a relationship between
that and the lesser metals which are
less precious but are also harder and
are stronger and so it's not just a
simple positive to negative thing
so as you move down the hierarchy the
gold offers
is the most precious metal it offers but
it's also soft it's malleable it doesn't
it's not hardened yet and so because of
it it's
uh
and as you as you move down then then
the the lower metals are
are less pure less let's say uh
less precious but then they're less rare
as well they're more common they're
bigger
think about that they're bigger and they
also are
more stronger but then ultimately
they're also in a way more fragile and
so
that's so the idea that for example the
roman the roman
empire would kind of
splinter and then create all these
nations in europe
and that are that are kind of
independent
i don't see why that's an issue for you
like i don't see why that's a problem
the idea that that rome would kind of
splinter into like multiple states
uh just like it just like in the image
of the statue with like the
the toes that are made of alloy that are
that are made of a mix of iron and clay
i think that that you can understand
that so it's not
you know so it's
yeah it's not just like a simple
positive to negative um
so yeah that's the way that i see it and
so and so it also has to do with time
like it's babylon is in a way the first
empire
you know and it's
you could say that it's kind of like the
first memory that we have you know
sometimes
you know
sometimes people make fun of the fact
that in scripture
there's you know we talk about the the
bible has that the earth is seven
thousand years old but it's like
i know people like that that
number isn't totally arbitrary because
our memory is about 7 000 years old it's
like after
around 7 000 years old we are not
connected to whatever was there like
whatever civilization you can find
before that
we just don't have any connection to it
like we it's like i said it's like these
little stupid statuettes that they find
in the ground and that no one knows what
they're for no but we do have a memory
of babylon babylon is part of the thread
which leads us to today and so but it is
in a way that first one especially in
terms of in terms of like jewish and
christian
tradition so
all right and so let's see
gideon you asks
says christ is risen indeed he is risen
greeting jonathan from the materialist
worldview prominent theory
a prominent theory of where our moon
came from is a large space rock
colliding with the earth when it was
still molten rock and knocking off a
large part when the when which then
began to orbit the earth and became the
moon on the other side of the material
spectrum you have the ancient alien type
theory
of how the moon is actually a giant
spaceship in which the aliens came to
our solar system what symbolism do you
see in one theory c
meaning to state that the moon is just
another piece of earth and not that
special while the other theory treats it
as something entirely foreign it claims
it would prove how humans owe all their
intelligent technology to aliens if the
lizard people would stop covering up the
truth
just weird questions man
so all right i'm gonna try to find a
nugget in that weird question because so
all right so
the idea that the moon is like
the idea that the moon is like the
feminine of the sun right that the moon
is like a mirror that it reflects
the light of the sun
means that it is the second it's the you
know it's the the second
ruler of the sky it's not the first one
it's the one that rules at night and not
only that but it's also let's say the
thing in the heavens that covers itself
in darkness and covers itself it light
and so it moves from light to darkness
so it wanes between identity and
non-identity and so so you could see
your little the way you frame it is a
good way to
to kind of frame it in a kind of weird
modern way which is that
right so on the one hand it is it is us
and it reflect reflects and on the other
hand it's dark and it actually is an
image of chaos and potential and and
strangeness and so
um
sure why not you know and so so that
that that might uh
help you understand at least understand
why those two theories are there but i'm
sure that the one about the alien
spaceship is a pretty marginal theory i
just i just i'm pretty sure about that
or maybe that's why it's dealing with
aliens too
um all right let's see if we have a
question so i'm going to move towards
the patreon questions let's see if
there's a
question
in the chat that i can answer
um
okay what would be the connection with
the blood and water that came from
christ's side and the conversion of
centurion
would he have
understood the hebrew symbolism of the
blood and the water
um
i don't know i think that for sure in
terms of the
the the centurion there was like a lot
of stuff going on that i think made him
realize what was happening i think that
part of it
was probably
the darkness as well you know that the
darkness came while christ was dying
and
you know and it's it's not super clear
like what that means that there's water
and blood that came out and
you know i mean what it looked like so i
don't know
i don't you're right i never thought
about that before like the blood and the
water in the centurion
why it is that that would be the thing
that made him understand
yeah
all right patreon
alexander says
i recently have become more
fascinated by the crisis and collapse of
the roman republic and the rise of the
empire
caesar's crossing the rubicon seems to
be a true symbolism happens moment in
history in luke's epic poem
farsalia caesar encountered the spirit
of rome as a goddess or bride in
distress when he reaches the river
do you know of any biblical parallels to
this or do you have any thoughts
on how this story might fit into the
christian story
thank you so much
um
i've never thought about that well for
sure i mean for sure the crossing of the
river
you know that's
that really as a symbolism moment
happened like a symbolism happens moment
and so you have to understand that
crossing the river is just crossing
identities and so
you know
crossing so the rubicon was was the
symbolic limit of the roman territory
and the army wasn't allowed to cross the
river in order to enter into rome and so
for sure crossing the river was
manifesting uh change
and was kind of manifesting a
you know it's like if you want to
understand a biblical symbolism of that
you can understand that like when the
israel crossed the jordan
to take over uh
to take over uh
the
jericho
you know that's similar to what caesar
was doing here he's crossing the river
to kind of conquer the land and so to
kind of enter as a as a new leader so
that's that's what you see when the
israelites cross the jordan
and you can also see a similar image
when um
constantine wins the battle on the
bridge you know
you know it is an image of the crossing
of the waters you can understand it also
as
as the flood you know and as
israel leaving egypt and crossing the
red sea so like this crossing of the
water is a marking of transition
but for sure the story of of israel and
jericho is the best one in terms of um
in terms of that um
so all right
so drew mcmahon asked hi jonathan you've
talked before about how laughing is a
form of losing control is crying weeping
also a form of losing control or is it
different in scripture jesus christ so i
imagine it's fundamentally different
thank you
and so
so i think that
crying is some is crying is it's funny
because it is kind of interesting to
think about the difference
crying is definitely it has to do with
compassion and so in a way it is a
losing control but it's not the same in
this especially crying out of compassion
it has to do with
let's say something letting something
from the outside
affecting you
and so when there's a matter in which
you can
you can have a cold heart right you see
that in scripture when
the um
when the pharaoh for example refuses to
let the israelites go it says that god
hardened his heart and so you can have a
hard heart and you can you can stop
yourself from experiencing compassion
um whereas i think that
this is what so i think that in in terms
of of crying that that's different you
know
so
but it's a good it's it's
a it's it's a good um
thing to think about i probably need to
meditate on it more in order to kind of
understand it better
all right so hunter newborn so davis
florida asked in my question to make it
i know i haven't been through all the
questions
um
i think it's important to understand
that there's a lot of questions at the
outset like 70 something questions and i
really reasonably can't answer more than
50. so it is possible
that just so that some of your questions
don't make it so sorry about that if if
that's the case
hunter newborn asked hey jonathan why
does participation have to be in the
church as we understand the church why
can living through christ in the world
and in society not being in not be the
participatory context of praise do we
not take communion when we eat the flesh
and drink the wine in life not only in
the church is the body of christ not the
people in the church
the people and the church not then the
world which we can constitute can the
cosmic ministry only give a hint of
itself through participation in the
church in the strict sense
i've not been to church since a teenager
now 24 but have only ever felt a glimpse
of the mystery and of christ living
in and around me when outside the church
and he says if you destroy my confidence
in this position i might i may find
myself forced to go to church
so try very hard to do so uh no it's
simple it's a hierarchy you have to
understand it as a hierarchy and so
you're right that
there's a manner in which let's say the
body of christ or that the kind of that
the body of of god fills up all of
reality
and we participate in that and there are
like you said glimpses there are
there are signs there are you know
intimations of that
in everything we do and it is possible
to a certain extent to find
you know god hiding behind all phenomena
and behind all interactions
but i think that for sure the the the
the church that christ instituted is in
a certain manner the culmination of that
and so it is a deliberate body of
of communion in love
and it is a deliberate body of
celebration
of the highest mystery and of
participation ritual participation in
that mystery and so
although i think
you're right that you know you can
you can have these intimations all over
i do think that to to participate in
a body to stand next to people and to
celebrate the same thing and to
participate in the same mystery
is in a certain manner
is ultimately the the kind of thing that
holds the world together
because it is attentive to the attentive
to the highest and so if you participate
in a sports team or in some smaller
version of a of a group you know you can
have these kind of intimations and kind
of feel connected
but
yeah ultimately things have to be
aligned towards the highest good i think
so hope that helps
so champ ja jans
or yance hi jonathan do you think the
ancient and symbolic world you've been
trying to convey to us is generally
universal before the enlightenment
scientific revolution modernity i ask
this because i'm going to study great
text in college and i would love to know
if i can apply mathews to the language
of creation your symbolic insight to all
other ancient texts some examples being
homer thucydides greek plays and other
ancient poetry another ancient text for
sure definitely no no i think
i think that
you know the the
the approach of the an analogical
approach is the one that would have been
pretty universal i think in all cultures
and so
i think that
i think that it was maybe more implicit
sometimes in the ancient text because
they would just imbibe it and live it
and so
one of the one of the advantages of our
moment is that it's big it's less we
have more difficult participating in it
because we're
a little alienated from
the most participative aspect of
symbolic
living
but because of that
we actually
are
capable of explicitly understanding it
more and so it's a trade-off and it's a
and it's interesting because it's a
trade-off that that i remember mature my
brother
talk about
a long time ago where he was like
he was saying
if we kind of explicitly study symbolism
you know what are we doing like are we
helping or are we making it worse
you know and uh i guess we came to the
conclusion that it was best to go this
way but that's a real question right
so i think you're right no i think you
can definitely and i think you might if
you're able to really imbibe the the
right analytical thinking i think that
you might have some insights that a lot
of people aren't able to
to have
you know um so that's what i think
so garrett wittner says hello jonathan i
was hoping you could shed some light on
thorns as a barrier is this a thing if
so is there such a thing as ascending
past the barrier of thorns
finally do thorns have a different
function based on where you stand in
relation to them looking forward to more
god's dog yeah
um
so
i mean i'm not sure i understand what
you mean so of course the thorns are a
barrier you can see it in scripture the
idea that god makes
these
thorns grow but you can understand it
like um for example like a great example
of that you see it in
the story the disney movie of sleeping
beauty where the thorns grow around the
castle and become like this like
protective
you know uh structure around it and that
the prince has to come and
the prince has to come in order to be
able to be led in to the thorns
um and so if you look at my image of
everything you'll see that that's how i
did it i put the thorns as a band around
let's say the
the garden
as a kind of barrier and so you know
barbed wire is exactly that by the way
that's what barbed wire is
um and so yeah
yeah yes ascending pacifier of thorns
would be a very good let's say story
trope if you're going to use it
mason asks hey jonathan is heaven
in your brother's book and in your own
work your kid to plato's realm of the
forums if not
how is it different
um
so it's definitely similar i think the
problem
the problem
with
um
the problem with plato's realm of the
forums is that it's not it's it's more
intelligences that are coming down from
heaven it's not
forms i don't think it's formed in the
same way that he talked about it it's
more like active intelligences that are
intelligent patterns that are causal so
that's why you know i think that the
hierarchy of the gods
you know this idea of a hierarchy of
gods or a higher care principalities is
closer to how reality works than just
the idea of forms and also
the duality of like just forms and
and let's say
shadows or manifestations of those forms
i think is also a little simplistic in
terms of understanding how it works and
if you understand it as a hierarchy of
intelligent patterns then you can
understand how the patterns
lower patterns embed themselves
fractionally in higher patterns and so
they kind of all fit into each other and
so that makes it i think that that's a
better
that's a better um understanding and so
this is going to be a little technical
but
so you could understand that as a at a
higher level
the forms that exist
the patterns that exist below
are indefinite there's an indefinite
amount of them
and so
and but they all they all fit
inside
the higher
pattern
so good a good way of of uh of and and
they're held by the higher pattern so it
means that you don't have the problem of
thinking like do the form of this or
that exist like
does the form of these or that little
details of reality exist because they
exist by being held
they have a lower and lower existence
let's say by being held by higher and
higher
patterns so a simple example would be
like
right so
you have a pattern of dog let's say
and so
how many dog how many species of dogs
exist
and the answer is an indefinite amount
of species of dogs there's an indefinite
amount and there could be more
who knows
and there's also an indefinite amount of
ways in which you could actually cut
into the speciation of dogs in a certain
manner that isn't arbitrary but it
doesn't totally matter because all the
species of dog are contained in the dog
and then you can keep going up and that
dog and other animals are contained in
higher categories so there's an
indefinite amount of them and the way
you could cut them up
it's not totally arbitrary like i said
but you could cut them up in this way or
that way but it wouldn't matter because
they're held up higher and so you just
keep going like that until you reach
you know the divine logos itself and we
realize that the divine logos is hiding
behind all
hierarchies of of being and all category
structures um
[Music]
so i think that that's a better way to
to understand it and one which leads to
less
problems
at least i think at least the less
problem so hopefully that's helpful
all right so ethan b asks regarding the
symbolism of flowers in the last q a i
was wondering is there a connection to
what you had said earlier in the same q
a about the highest form of sexuality
being abstinence and submission
to something greater than itself a
flower could be considered the apex of
the plant's expression before sexual
union
is the offering
of the flowers symbolic
of that higher form
of abstinence
i have to think about it i'm not sure i
totally see where the question is going
a flower could be considered the apex of
the plant's expression of sexual union
is the offering of the flower you mean
like offering i don't remember what it
was that i talked about in the last q a
about flowers
is it about like offering flowers to
someone you love or something like that
sorry man
i feel like i'm gonna let you down on
this question
all right so white lawrence asks
in terms of participation can you talk
about the difference between music video
but music movies video games and
painting video games seem to be more
active and participatory than watching a
movie listening to music or going to an
art museum however i don't think that's
necessarily means video games are
superior form of art any thoughts and so
yeah video games are definitely
participatory and i think that
the video games are interesting like
because they they do end up strangely
uh embodying
uh like a symbolic structure
really actually quite clearly because
usually especially like in uh
because in in video games there's always
like a goal
and then there's a frame which is like
the level or the you know the or like
the world itself has it needs to have a
limit because it's it has to be bound
and then there's ways in which to reach
higher levels and so there's these
hierarchies of of levels that you attain
and so there's something if you watch my
video on uh on the
donkey kong i talk about that a little
bit
and so it's definitely quite
participative
i think that
yeah i think that
there's something also that's kind of
low about video games and i'm not sure
how that is that's it seems like video
games will always kind of remain in this
more popular sphere
um
but maybe that sometimes is actually the
place where more mysteries are hidden
sometimes you know i always kind of joke
but it's like there's the reason why
dante wrote in la in italian and none in
latin and there's a reason why
the gospels are written in koine greek
instead of like a more literary form so
yeah
um
let's see if we got some questions in
the chat that i want to answer
so
you good to good
you're good to get
you said that christ said yes to god
telling adam if he ate the fruit of the
tree he would die was man always meant
to die and resurrect
did
taking the fruit improperly make death
bitter
and so
so this is something that i've
tried to explain but it's like i always
feel like i'm on really
dangerous ground when i'm talking about
this because
what i'm trying to often hint at is that
death and glory
are
like the same thing they're made of the
same stuff it it's just that
one is the breakdown of the person
and the other is like the ecstatic
giving
or the ecstatic
overflowing of the person
but it it uh both of them seem to be
made of the same stuff and so
so the idea is that
christ restores
glory through his death
you know
but that's it's just when i say it i'm
like i know people won't understand what
i'm saying it's very difficult to uh
to talk about that particularly so
hopefully people are kind of
understanding what i'm saying
but we're
yeah all right so bob briggs asks if in
father stephen freeman's book everywhere
president he talks about the similar
patterns between
the version of the theophany icon with
christ standing on two boards in the
jordan and the anastasia's icon yeah
would you speak about this similarity in
more detail this has been a revelation
from me seeing saint john the foreigner
in the same position in both icons and
what
you and lord of spirits has taught me
about the water being
the abyss and or chaos yeah so for those
who don't know
so in the image of the anastasis which
is the image of the herring of hell
which is christ going down into hell he
usually is standing on the doors of hell
that are
that are uh broken and sometimes the
doors of hell are like in a cross it's
kind of standing on this cross
um not always but often that's what it
is and so in the image of the
theophany icon which is the image of
baptism you will also
see christ not always but often you'll
see him standing on similar
pieces of wood that are below and
sometimes you'll see like snakes coming
out from the side or snakes under the
door let's say and so this of course
really does have to do with the fact
that
to help us understand what baptism is
that it is a descent
into
death and to chaos
and that there is a relationship
definitely relationship between
christ descending into hades and you
descending into
to death right
and so it's like we die with christ and
we're when we're being baptized kind of
descend into death and you find it in
the image
in the prayers that are told when
someone is baptized in the orthodox
church you will find all these prayers
which talk about you know the dragons
that are in the water and it's just like
chasing away of the dragons and the and
the the the monsters that are in the
deep and that is what is happening
um
and so so yeah they're definitely
they're definitely trying to help you
understand the connection
between baptism
theophany and between uh
between the resurrection and the the
descendant the 80s
all right so silas alan asked
so how do you explain the difference of
christian theosis
verse
says the noose versus other spiritual
practices of opening the third eye
and so
i think it's not
i think that they're not completely uh
different from each other at least in
terms of
it doesn't express it itself exactly in
the same way but you'll find in the
philocalia in the text the mystical text
of the eastern church
you'll find the idea it doesn't express
itself as a third eye like in the
forehead but it expresses itself as the
eye of the heart
so
it's not exactly the same but it's
similar in the sense that it's the idea
of like
a central heart right a heart in the
middle which joins the two visions
together and so that's what i think the
third eye
is often referred to it has to do with
reaching an insight which joins
opposites
together in unity
you know and so you could have a fractal
experience of that where it's like you
have these you have two two things and
you're able to kind of see how they
connect you know symbolism is something
that
that that is part of that and so you
have a little mini experience of insight
and that insight appears
as as the the place where opposites join
and become one
and i think that that's what the fathers
mean when they talk about the eye of the
heart which is also which is also this
like central heart
um
but in a certain manner in terms of
christianity it's not just a
it's not just a mental exercise right
it's not just a
i mean although i'm not
suggesting that that the the it's not
just about knowledge in the
in the most immediate sense it really is
also about
you know
concentration and
and embodiment you know and so
maybe that's the difference but it's
definitely not it's not completely
unrelated
all right so duratia says the pattern of
losing your garments of skin water and
ascending into heaven fascinates me
you mentioned biblical examples of the
rapture but for us christians that
should also be our baptism i guess and
what about the story of saint francis
who gives us his clothes and goes naked
into the world i think in some stories
the bishop covers him with his cloak
rises into the air as he receives the
sting mara and then on the same day by
his sword
water sprang out of a stone
um i never heard that story
and so
yeah for sure there's definitely a
relationship with
i mean baptism
is something like that you know you you
you christ especially the cries baptism
christ goes into the water and yours too
right because if you're christmated
especially in the orthodox church you're
christmated on the same day and so
you you go down the water you come out
and then you receive the anointing from
above you receive the spirit which comes
from above the light which comes from
above um and so it's like this joining
of you know above and below
uh it's not exactly an ascension and so
yeah
yeah
all right kevin patterson says we use
techne as garments of skin but we
receive technique from patterns above so
are the heavenly patterns using
us as their body when they when we wield
technique
also who creates those patterns
so you need to watch my um you
definitely need to watch my talk on the
book of enoch you know that's
what it's kind of dealing with and so
yes you could understand it
you could understand to a certain extent
that
that we it's possible that we are
participating in the bodies of these
patterns these higher patterns when we
are involved in technology so we are
technology because it is an increase of
power
can definitely be
a kind of embodying
of of these patterns because it
increases their power in the world so
let's let's find a simple example that
is
clear because it's let's say it's
negative and so
so for example you would have a pattern
a euphoric pattern a pattern of euphoria
a pattern which is the capacity for
humans to kind of move into
a dizzy type of consciousness or a
lose some aspect of their consciousness
um and so people develop wine
as a as a related to a garment of skin
you know we have to remember that
wine comes right after the flood it's
like
it's related to that as well and so
but then
using technology the past or the pattern
of euphoria the pattern of drunkenness
or whatever
that pattern
wants to increase itself wants to
increase his body and so we develop more
potent forms of alcohol
we start to develop other types of
things and then we end with like cocaine
or whatever
and so that's an example where you can
see like a heavenly pattern which is
using us to embody itself and to gain
power
through our
attention and its capacity to kind of
gather our attention
so
you can understand that for a lot of of
technologies
hope that makes sense all right so max
blaze
asks hi jonathan to discuss the
difference between spiritual reality and
say pagan deities zeus thor etc
and narrative characters like captain
america is this a qualitative difference
or just one
of scale and power of the spirits
involved and what does a narrative
reality break
what point does a narrative reality
break into the world
so there's definitely a difference
between
fictional characters and
the gods they're not completely
unrelated but
let's say
captain america doesn't have uh
let's say the body of captain america
is in the comic books and the movies and
all of that stuff and and to a certain
extent in in the fans
he does find some kind of embodiment in
the fans but it's very limited you know
i don't think captain america
has the capacity to change things
or maybe a little bit but very little in
the world
compared to the ancient gods so the
ancient gods
were the patterns that manage entire
aspects of society
and so they would have
effective power and control over those
aspects people would worship them people
would sacrifice to them
you know um
you know people would
it's a name
their children their you know their
things in relation to that things would
be dedicated so it's not that there
isn't a little bit of that of captain
america i mean people buy stuff with
captain america on it but it's very
limited it doesn't become a it's not a
principality that
that actually manages so i tend to
sometimes think that
seems like those little
small like kind of fictional characters
that they they become
probably embodiments of higher patterns
like just
you know
sometimes they're like aspects of christ
you know sometimes they're aspect of
lower
lower patterns you know like virtues and
different different
lower patterns um so that's the way that
i see that
i hope that makes sense sometimes when i
say these things i'm like people
i'm gonna think i'm spewing total
nonsense all right anton o'landerson
says let's see if maybe there's a
question here
in the chat as well
let's see
so brandon burns as
how do we know christ in our lifetime
presumably thousands saw his miracles in
person and didn't know him some
disciples didn't recognize him after the
resurrection etc
i mean
you know him the way that christ's you
know that the the christ and the
scripture says that you know him you
know you you you have to know him in the
little ones
you know you have to recognize him in
the little ones you have to discern his
body in the eucharist
you have to
you know
and then ultimately you have to kind of
see him as the source of all things and
so seem hidden
in all aspects of reality
you know but in the the faces of those
that you love and that love you
that's where you
mostly encounter christ
and also to a certain extent i think in
in relationship to authority to a
certain extent which is that
what we receive from above
is
is a is an image of what we receive from
higher up even so i think that those are
the the three places you know from
well not three but let's say from from
in the littlest ones like hidden the
idea of seeing christ the littlest ones
is an image of being able to see him in
all things you know and hidden in the
poor hidden in those that are afflicted
it's like that's where
that's the true
test of a
christian you could say
um
yeah and then any other places i said
hopefully that makes sense
all right
anton o'landerson says hi jonathan hope
you're well to me there are two major
patterns in the world today it's the
pattern of increasing control i.e the
coming of the b system then there's also
the increasing popularity of pagan of
the new age which is vaguely uniting
many spiritual beliefs in their worship
and in their drug-induced ceremonies do
you think that those two patterns will
ever unite will the [ __ ] ever ride the
beast in that way for example i find
that a lot of
ayahuasca promoters are also promoting
crypto sorry if the question is vague
but i'd love to hear your thoughts so i
understand what you're saying i think
you're right i think that there are
these two patterns you know the pattern
the second one is
is not just paganism and you age but
it's just like fragmentation in general
and the breakdown of narratives into
multiple narratives the breakdown of
of like cults into many different gods
and different things that are being
served and worshiped and followed and so
you have on the one hand an image of of
absolute control and
and and uh total authority and on the
other hand you have an image of
kind of an archaic breakdown and
anarchic influences so i think that
those two things are in a certain way
the [ __ ] riding the beast that's
already what it is because
they both
give each other legitimacy you know they
they give each other
it's a possibility
and so as the
let's say as the [ __ ] becomes
stronger and stronger then
there's a need for the beast to be more
powerful so it's like as the anarchy
grows and as
people are idiosyncratic then you need
the methods of control to be stronger
because it's like the system's not going
to hold you can't
like you know a [ __ ] is not a
sustainable
society you could say um
and so you need these you need to kind
of add control constantly in order to
keep it
holding together
um
so yeah so anyway so that's that's what
i think
but you know in in the revelation says
that at some point the beast kills the
[ __ ]
you know
so
it seems like
that's definitely what happened at the
end of weimar
and uh it's like i'm not sure how it's
gonna play out because i'm really
surprised like you said to notice
that the very
image like the very let's say pattern of
the [ __ ]
is becoming
authoritarian in itself right this kind
of weird imposition of of idiosyncrasy
um so i don't know like how far that can
go it's definitely
in a way
in a way it's a little surprising to me
but
all right so
so g garcia says how can we throw the
ring back into mortar
other stories may magically seal or bind
a technology evil being but there is
always potential for some someone
to take it or release it guardians of
the galaxy lock the stone away
only for thanos to take it but in lord
of the rings the ring is destroyed
can you take away from these stories
so
i think the image of the ring being
destroyed is
fine i think it's okay
um but i think that it's not the most
christian story i think that the most
christian story
is that the ring is transformed you know
and that technology is ultimately
transmuted
into
something which serves the highest good
so i think that that's actually that's
actually the image of the heavenly
jerusalem
which is i think the right image
but um
i don't know how that happens
because it's just at this point like are
you really gonna throw the ring into the
fire like
what is that how would that even be
possible it's like the ring is basically
a giant you know network of satellites
it's like it's so it's so big the ring
is so huge and it's so encompassing that
yeah i don't see how you're gonna get
how you're gonna throw it in the fire
um
all right so
mary heather howerton
says hi jonathan what is the symbolism
of wind i keep noticing it when i read
the old testament so i was curious thank
you
so the wind there are different types of
wind but you could understand it in
general the wind as just the
invisible
acting on the visible that's the way to
pretty much uh understand wind and so
you can see it like um
that the wind of god that revealed dry
land when the red sea is being separated
so that wind of god
is
very similar to the let's say the
the spirit of god which blows on the
water at the beginning of the
of scripture and that ultimately
participates in bringing up the the
earth and so it's like it is this
invisible action on on potential
um
but the wind can also be
something like
patterns that don't find body so
sometimes you can have a negative aspect
you see that especially in the book of
um
of kohelet in the book of ecclesiastes
where it says you know everything is
is uh is like
his vanity of vanities everything is
breath of breath right it's chasing
after wind chasing after breath and so
this idea of these of these these
flighty patterns that can't actually
find body and just you know
and so you can understand that as
that's also a possibility for for wind
um
so it depends on the context but i think
in general it has to do with of
something that invisible
the invisible acting on the visible
somehow
all right so ll asks i am new to the
symbolic interpretation of the bible and
trying to get an understanding of how
it's a description of the structure of
reality i don't want to misunderstand
important things
i wonder if the theory of relativity
and other laws of nature would be
considered the word of god
since it's also a kind of description of
the structure of reality
are the laws of nature like the stories
in the bible but in a different format
um
uh so uh
maybe i don't know it's
you know you know the way that i
so i don't think that these laws these
these laws of of nature the way that
people think about it today i don't
think that these are
let's say primary
in terms of laws
people are gonna find me weird to say
that i think that the the
the structure of your experience
is far more primary and close to the
word of god
than
the description of these like like super
abstract
physical
laws
because those super abstract physical
laws
they are
seen through the the frame of your
experience so that's why
the way to kind of
the way to understand symbolism
is usually to
stay or come closer to
this embodied experience that you have
and that the abstractions they're not
there's nothing wrong with something
like the theory of relativity it's fine
uh it's helpful to make to do certain
things and to understand certain things
but it is
uh it is a lesser
truth
in the sense that it's less it's it's
less important to you to know right so
it's like
let's say
let's say the law that that if you fall
if you hit your head on a rock like if
you fall down and you crack your head
open you'll die is more important than
the law of
that of relativity than the the theory
of relativity
does that make sense oh that makes sense
all right so keenan wang says can you
talk about the symbolism of envy it
seems almost like a second sin in
genesis
after
pride cain and satan are both thought of
as envious yes
and so
yes definitely you know
definitely so envy is related to pride
in the sense that
envy is thinking that you are owed
something that
that what what you do not have you
should have
and so it is definitely
related to pride so cain
thinks that he should have this or that
blessing from god he thinks that he's
gonna owe that but
he isn't
and so
that's what that's what happens and so
you can understand the same similar in
terms of satan or the the you know the
evil one or the
the contenders that
you know he thinks that
he is owed something and that that it
belongs to him
yeah so that's the way that i would
explain that
what are your thoughts on islam my
goodness are muslims anti-christ
according to orthodoxy and is the
religion itself a heresy
so
i think that the traditional position
has always been that that islam is a
heresy
you know
that's all i can say
all right
so russ frost says what is the symbolism
of kissing
so i mean
it has to do with
expression i mean so when you speak
so when it your mouth is two things it's
like it's it's
where you
you let's say brings bring things inside
you but also how you kind of
express and so i don't think it's that
surprising
you know that we would have developed
something like kissing and so it's like
i put my mouth
on something
to signify my
attention to it my care for it
um
and also
yeah you know
that's as close as as as as i'm gonna
get with that but it's it's probably
very very primordial it's probably one
of the most primordial images i wish i
had more insight on it right now
well i'll be thinking about it that's
for sure
so christian christ
says christ enriched indeed he has risen
all the disciples followed christ to the
cross the disciples saint john is the
only one who isn't martyred in doing so
does him being the only one actually to
actually follow christ to the cross
there any significance here oh that's a
super interesting
man that is a super interesting idea i
never thought about that
i never thought about that
that the fact that
because
saint john wasn't he how did he die
wasn't he
so i'm not sure like
are you saying that
and not all the disciples died on the
cross
huh
yeah and i'm not sure about what you're
saying
huh
um so adjafka says
um
what is the meaning of moving far away
to marry a foreigner
um so there are different they're
different um
they're different uh
symbolism to that especially it depends
like is it moving away and marrying a
foreigner or is it having a foreigner
come to your land and marrying them
that's different that's that's
definitely different so
if you move away and marry a foreigner
then it usually means that in a way you
are going to
lose yourself to that
land and that your children will
your seed will be taken by the foreigner
is a good way to understand that
now
for example in proverbs that tends that
there's a there's a warning about that
about doing that
but
there's also a way in which that can be
kind of flipped and you see that it has
that also has to do with the end
so there's a sense in which
there's a sense in which
at the end of something you know you
marry
the foreigner
and that
it also becomes like a weird way to
a weird moment of transformation where
the world is kind of transformed and
there's a
so you see that in the story of esther
like the story of esther man that story
that's weird it's a weird story
where where esther marries the foreign
king and he's kind of hidden there and
then reveals herself to the salvation of
her people
um
you see that in the story of joseph
right so joseph
goes out and then when the world is
about to end like the famine is about to
kill his family then something happens
some like flip that
becomes that is able to kind of preserve
his own people
um so that's the other side of marrying
the foreigner you see that
in christ becoming roman marrying rome
basically you see the same sort of
imagery so it's a dual symbolism
so daniel says have you read have you
ever read the brothers caramel what are
your thoughts on it yes i have read the
brothers karamazov loved it i mean i
think dostoevsky is wonderful
his insights on on human
the human psyche and human relations are
quite profound
that's for sure um
so reuben corp says you mentioned once
that you had watched terence malek's a
hidden life and thought it was a good
example of a person attempting to show
a person's life from the christian point
of view could you elaborate more on what
you meant or perhaps talk about any of
the notable symbols or ideas appearing
in the story think especially
about the scene
with the church painter if you remember
my wife and i watched this film a year
or so ago and it quickly became our
favorite and when we can watch and
re-watch any time man that's good that
you can do that i can't re-watch that
movie boy that movie was
intense like it was really intense and
it was very
difficult for me to watch because
because it really
manifests like one of the things that
christ says that is you know the idea
that there are
to understand it like when christ says
there are those who plant the seed and
there are those that reap and those that
plant and those that reap aren't the
same
and what that means is that
the planting of the seed in secret
that's the i mean can you imagine like
that's the hardest
and so that movie shows you someone who
is acting out of christian
virtue
and is acting out of a christian
uh conviction that
what let's say the government is doing
is immoral and against the kingdom of
god and
because of
it he loses everything you know and
and he has no
he's he's he's despised by all you know
and
and that his wife pays the price and his
family pays the price and everybody pays
the price for his
virtue it's like man it's tough to watch
but there are moments in the movie
though like there are these like moments
where malik shows
the seed being planted you know where
you can see even in the frustration
of the people accusing him
how
they're transformed kind of secretly
they're like transformed in their inner
parts but you don't see the fruits of it
and so
yeah it's really powerful but it's hard
i find it very hard to watch because
it was very
convicting you know and you think wow
what would i would do you know
because the other thing that he does
which is the hardest of all is that he
also doesn't accuse he doesn't
he doesn't decry he doesn't accuse he
doesn't rail against the system
he just accepts
the consequences of his actions
yeah
all right
so
manuel montiel says have mass become a
sort of totem to some it seems there's a
sort of religious impulse behind it
similar to wearing a crucifix
yeah for sure that's definitely for sure
it's it's it's become like uh
it's become superstitious in the way
that we use the word superstitious
people wear it as a superstition
so which is not necessarily bad like
super i actually don't find
superstitions completely bad they they
they can they serve a purpose but um
it seems like that's it's become that
um
ross bird says
hi johnson what is going on in matthew
27 when it says that many bodies of
saints were raised from the dead when
jesus died
the direct cause seems to have been
jesus's death not his resurrection but
then it also says that the saints come
out of the tombs and went into the holy
city after his resurrection yeah i know
man
i don't know how to touch that story man
that's a that's it
yeah i don't know what to tell you man
that's that's that's crazy that's a
crazy story
and it's hard to really it's hard to
really like
like what does it mean like the people
that have just died or the people that
died
years ago or what like what does it mean
man
it's a really tough one
yep that's a really tough one
yeah all right sorry
all right anderson ralstrad said hi
jonathan to me it looks like if we
worship god what we need will come our
way because our needs are transformed by
worship however i don't understand how
technology can come about in the new
jerusalem without man putting his own
will over god's will and insight
and well so in the image of the new
jerusalem
you really see that that that you can
understand it like the
the outer wall
it says first of all it says that the
the kings
bring their glory right into the
into the the city and so there's a sense
in which
the
the outer part you know or the technical
part or the outer part of the garments
of skin they become the expression of
that which is inside and so it's like we
worship god and then
god fills the world with with his with
his presence and so then the bodily
expression becomes the fully
fully an expression of
of
of god so
it's not it's not it it's not that how
can i say this it's like i always be
it's like when i say these things i was
careful it's like no this is something
which happens all the time right this is
something which
which happens all the time which is that
if
if the elements of of the glass are are
let's say
attentive to it their purpose and that
they're bound together properly to their
purpose the more they are
the more the glass will be full of its
truth
and that's true for any level of being
so the more that the elements
that are
part of that
being
are attentive to its purpose
and to
why they're there in the first place
then that will become an exemplary
the most exemplary example of that thing
and it will be full of the glory it'll
be it'll be full of glory of what it is
that it is so you can
man i feel like no one's gonna
understand this um
so i mean think about it
think about it like okay let's use the
basketball team again let's use the
sports team so you have a sports team
and the sports scene that is the most
attentive and that all the players are
the most attentive to the purpose of the
sports team they are the they're going
to become the best sports team
they're going to be the one that
represents the sport the best they're
going to be full of the glory of
basketball
and that and and and that all their
gestures they'll have less idiosyncratic
gestures they'll have less gestures
which are which are going away from the
purpose of what they're accomplishing
and more of them will will be toward
that and so the body like their bodies
will start to manifest that purpose
they'll become embodiments of that and
all of them together will become like a
glorious body of basketball
and so that's what the new jerusalem is
but like for everything for the entire
cosmos
where all things
attending and looking up towards their
source now become the fullest version of
that which they are and their
participation in that source
so that's why
so when you when you think of technology
like you have to be careful it just
means these external means so
you know you i don't know like what
you know i don't know what the
technology what the technology is it
doesn't matter in a way so you
yeah anyway sorry sorry sorry sorry
hopefully this is useful
all right okay
okay so
so anders verostrad
no sorry no no no no i think i've
already answered that one
all right okay so conor mitchell asks
can you discuss the symbolism
surrounding greek fire the secretive
technology used to protect the christian
roman empire and its symbolism has any
relevance to the issue of tech today
um
yeah it's a pretty powerful tool like it
was a pretty powerful those who don't
know what the greek fire was
was that the boats the byzantine boats
would have a kind of cannon
they don't know exactly what it was but
it shot something probably like oil or
petrol or something
and then it would be lit a flame and so
the water would
would burn
um and and so that's how they would take
out
enemy fleets is that they would
basically
like light the ocean on fire you know
lightly the sea on fire and that way
they
they became in like an impenetrable um
uh it was very difficult to attack
constantinople from the sea
and so
i mean
if you want to understand it's like
that's
that's what war like that's war right
that's war setting
setting potential on fire you know
that's what that's what war is so yeah
all right
so anna and herrera said just curious
how you see therapist therapy
symbolically thanks so
i mean i think i see i see therapists
and therapy as a
they're trying to do something that
let's say the religion used to try to do
which is try to kind of remember people
to kind of co-cure them to bring them
together and so i'm not against some of
the aspects of of therapy if you look at
the way that the church fathers talk
about in the filo in the philicalia
you'll see that they use therapeutic
let's say therapeutic methods in order
to
to kind of help people
free themselves from their passions
there's a wonderful book called orthodox
psychotherapy
which uh which my dad loves by the way
um
but i think that one of the let's say
the downside to that is really the fact
that often in the modern kind of therapy
session
there's a
kind of narcissism
because it's all about just you and
about you know like helping you become
better
and there isn't the sense in which that
happens through serving others and it
happens through loving others and you
know sometimes maybe some therapist but
a lot of it isn't like that it's like
it's just about
you know yourself and so i think that
that
that that can sometimes make it
problematic especially not just therapy
but especially like psychoanalysis man
psychoanalysis i think
not sure psychoanalysis really helps
anybody or like ultimately because it is
it is such a
it is such a kind of narcissism um
so like a good example like my dad is a
psychologist and so what my dad does
well he he's retired now but what he
used to do is he used to do only couples
therapy
because he thought you can't be in
therapy without someone you you at least
say you love and so if you have a
couple's therapy then it's like the
therapy is is happening in the communion
of the two people that's how the therapy
is actually functioning and it's not
just happening within you and within
your own thoughts and within your own
like little little idiosyncrasies and so
i thought that was a really good a good
insight about how humans
actually are
healed
um
so an ann herrera says yes preach well
i'm happy you like my answer and
oh all right arie fisher says hey
jonathan
if you're not going to make a video on
spiderman away home could you briefly
outline your thoughts on the film and so
arie i am going to make a video on it
and so but i'm going to probably make it
a patron-only video i was thinking of
doing that because it's actually
may 31st and i'm supposed to make my
patreon video today but i'm not gonna
make it today because it just this
month's been crazy i'll probably make it
tomorrow or the day after and it will
probably be
about spider-man in a way home so so
since you're asking that question you'll
be able to see it um and i will
be writing i wrote a um i wrote an
article for richard rowland's book the
sacramental imagination which he talked
about on the on our podcast and he's
kind of putting together so i finished
the article i sent it to him
and part of it is also an analysis of
spider-man knowing home and so uh yeah
so look forward to that guys
all right so jacobus rodden is asking
explain on the idea of god's right hand
left hand in terms of angels and demons
so this is something that i really
uh
i mentioned this a few times on this on
in my podcast which is that
in saint gregory of nissa sangre nissa
talks about
how every human is attributed an angel
and a demon and he says you know and
it's basically like the angel on the
right shoulder and the demon on the left
shoulder right that you see in
um
that you see in
the the cartoons right you see that in
the simpsons or whatever they're in like
tom and jerry
so you have these two influences and
he also interestingly enough puts them
in the same person in the service and
gregor nissa in the story of moses so he
has this sense that
the the the the angel and the demon are
um are aaron
so as aaron is the helper he's the the
brother he's the sustainer and so but
aaron is the one who kind of gives
advice but aaron in the in the
in the bible is both sides right so he
makes the golden calf
you know but he's also like the one that
that that kind of speaks in front of
moses so he has these two sides to him
you could say
and so interesting enough secret anissa
puts this idea of like a
of a helper and separates it into two
which is like the demon and the angel so
that's super interesting to think about
by the way
uh
and so
you could understand it as like the
transpersonal
aspect of you that there are two
extremes in like the transpersonal
aspect of yourself that which is
beyond you you know and that you
interact with so you have an aspect of
you but that is beyond you that you
interact with that is pulling you
towards the good and you have
an aspect which is also pulling you
towards fragmentation
um
and then you can imagine that there's a
cosmic version of that and that's the
one that
i was really excited to hear
father stephen deyoung talk about how
the church father sang gregor of
nandianzis i think is the one who said
that the angels of the left hand are the
demons and that they do the will of god
despite themselves
that they that they are there to kind of
scourge
us but that in doing so they ultimately
end up participating in our in our
salvation mysteriously
and so i thought that that was
interesting because it's like there's a
there's a microcosm version that saint
gregory of nisa talks about and then
there's this macro cosmic version
you know
that saint gregory talked the other
saint gregory talks about and they you
know they knew each other so
so i find that very interesting
definitely very interesting
so james oran says wouldn't the angel be
pulling you towards total order tyranny
if it were a true dichotomy
um
so
no i mean
in the the the hand of order the hand
the right hand and the left hand aren't
like ordering chaos that's not that's
not the right way to understand it the
left hand and the right hand are
moving towards the inside and then
moving towards the outside or moving up
and moving down
and so
in that way they're they're not the same
as just order and chaos
yeah so so the the right hand is but
there is a negative aspect to the right
hand i've talked about it which is the
the the negative aspect of the right
hand is the possibility of pride and
self-sufficiency you know and the the
negative and the positive aspect of the
left hand is something like
the capacity to move out of yourself and
to to
to be able to adapt towards
towards the strange right it's the fire
it's the fire of of uh of pentecost you
know and it's also saint paul
when he talks about being all things to
all people and you know being a
shape-shifter basically so this is the
but for sure in terms of angels and
demons now it's clearly
you know
one is zen is positive which moving up
and when a scene is negative pulling you
down but like
like i said it's like there's a
mysterious way in which that
participates in our salvation
at least according to saint gregory so
all right so charlie longoria says hello
jonathan in the past few weeks in the
united states
we've had this abortion controversy a
mass short of a baby formula and now
this horrifying and disgusting shooting
at elementary school i feel like these
are connected but can't articulate how
and why
i was wondering if you had any thoughts
on this
i don't know i mean they definitely are
connected in the sense that they are all
related to
the the
let's say the the opportunity the danger
the
the manner in which we deal with the
future with with children and so
they're definitely related in that way
but that's pretty much as much as i can
say i think
so joe kelly says my grandmother was on
the
board members that organized the media
the
menu i can't pronounce this word
medjugor peace conference which hosts
the marion visionaries in california
every year mary the eucharist and the
mysticism
of these visions is the foundation that
my family's faith was built on and we
are firmly rooted on the edge here in
california
i was wondering if you could talk about
the significance of our lady of
guadalupe and the idea
that the tilma
reconciles aztecan symbolism with the
western symbolism of the virgin mary and
so i don't know enough about
about that i don't even know what
the tilma is
so i probably couldn't
answer your question properly
um
um and so
what is the tillman of our ladies of
garuda
the mantle the cloak
so i don't know enough about that that
vision i'm sorry to tell you
and so i mean if it reconciles a second
symbolism with western symbolism of the
virgin mary then i think that that's
that would only that would definitely be
appropriate because
you know it's a vision that happened
in guadalupe and so
that might be that might be something
but i don't know enough about it so
sorry about that
all right
so bob briggs says love richard i can't
get enough of universal history so yeah
cool we just recorded an episode today
on the mongols on the on gog and magog
so man that was something it gets pretty
dark
because it's crazy stuff that happened
at that time during the mongol invasion
um
all right guys i actually
got through the questions usually like
this lasts about two hours for some
reason i was able to get to 50 questions
in less than that
so uh are there other questions in the
chat that you guys can
ask or if not then
we'll call it a night already
which might be a good idea because man
i'm tired
just been tired
all right guys i think then then we will
call it a night it's good to see
everybody glad to see it's good to read
your chat messages brad thanks for
showing up
and uh and uh stay tuned we'll have
videos coming i hope very soon the
patreon video i hope by tomorrow or
maybe the day after
and uh very soon and we'll talk to you
very soon all right guys bye-bye